first of all congrats on the movie I'm a
big fan of Peter Berg and Mark Wahlberg
when they pair up
vampa they have a camaraderie they've
done this a number of times what did you
expect they were gonna be like going in
and what did it actually end up being um
well I didn't really have any actual
expectations since you know I mean what
can I compare Pete Berg and Mark
Wahlberg to you know so
coming in I don't know I kind of
expected it to be like maybe like a good
old boys club or something like that but
there they would joke around and be like
cool with each other but Steve Steve
Steve yeah Pete and Mark would just they
were just so in the zone and so
efficient like like Marco come in and
just know everything like front and
backwards and sideways and like it was
just crazy to see like Pete like shot
him from the side and be like do like
the like the way that they would go back
and forth they was just like you got
exactly the best out of him is exactly
what Pete wanted as quickly as possible
it was just like I'd never knew that
Mark Wahlberg was that great of an actor
until I saw him work I same way I didn't
really know what to expect
III met Peter before we started filming
obviously and he kind of talked to me a
little bit about his process and you
know he is an actor he used to act a lot
and he told me a little bit about how it
would kind of drive him crazy the way
most films are done where you kind of
set up the camera and you kind of have
to stand there and say your lines and
then they have to stop and they move the
camera and you say your lines and he
told me about his style of shooting
which is like the antithesis of that
where he's got several cameras running
at the same time he doesn't cut you kind
of rehearse the scene a little bit like
like in a play and then you just kind of
go and he's giving you directions as
you're filming you know he tells you to
go back he doesn't
so I came in knowing that that was gonna
happen but I don't think anything can
really prepare you for that so it was a
totally new experience but it was it was
incredible and mark I mean like Rhonda
said he was he was amazing he knew
everything backwards and forwards and he
was generous with his time but also just
prepared and there to work and I was I
was I was impressed hope you both get to
get in on the action can you share like
a memorable day from filming uh well one
of our first days what our first days
where you know just kind of get the feel
for everything and then they're just
like okay guys we're to set everything
on fire and not like oh like there's
gonna be a fire over here like there's
just fire everywhere and and I I just
had a Pantene endorsement so and he
already wanted to shave my head for this
movie let's get that started he wanted
to shave my head it was like the one
thing he was super like on he was like I
want I want your head shaved it's gone
and I'm like Pete I got like a Pantene
deal you can't shave my head and so the
first day of shooting there's fire
everywhere and I'm like this is just
because he wanted my head bald and he's
gonna try and burn all my hair off today
I put so much fire retardant in my hair
I hadn't had no idea what it was that's
cold
really but yeah that was that was a
little bit of surprising and challenging
they tried to light my head on fire yeah
shooting from the ceiling when you see
it in the film just know that it's not
CGI oh there's a real fire filled the
house sequence first it was one of the
first things right yeah here's the fire
here's your head this is the direction
vibration
first day right and what's interesting
is you're on camera looking like you've
been through this like a hundred times
you're like whatever I have been through
it a hundred times no Thomas John that
fire stuff pretty casual by the end of
it the wood um I have a few fun
questions for you guys which I hopefully
you think you let's find out if they're
fun um what TV show would you love to
guest spot on Game of Thrones
alright a dragon where's my husband I
need do you have a favorite sci-fi or
fantasy film I mean he can't be Star
Wars I can't I can't
Star Wars forever Sarge my favorite
forever and ever and you can argue but
you can't argue I can't I can't disagree
with that but I just generally love the
genre so like any I would be in like the
worst life I've felt ever made and be
happy I love Minority Report I think
that's a really great movie and the
Steven Spielberg is gonna have a career
yeah got something he's gonna land on
his feet um
what film scared you as a kid Exorcist
and I saw it on TV the TV edited version
and I slept with the lights on in my
little sister's bed for a year yeah
Catholic school makes you think that
shit's really gonna happen that's
amazing
I can't Bambi I can't watch anything
that you collect
I collect mugs I collect mugs from like
talk shows and countries and all kinds
of people keep giving me months I don't
know I collect playing cards okay and I
used to collect watches but I stopped
that at some point did you get one of
the playing cards from the like whole
sets are just cards no offense guys do
you own any movie or TV show props
perhaps you wouldn't have happened to
borrow anything from you
no but I did steal the fluffy pillows
from
the Network Stars trailer great afro
how do you steal them do you just walk
out with them under your arms and no one
says yeah I was walking out like say
something I might have a pair of
tactical gloves okay I did steal the
boots to wear to the Royal Rumble but
then I brought them back really yeah you
see that was a mistake what TV show have
you watched all the way through more
than once
is there any Dragon Ball Z I don't think
I have before I run at a time my last
thing it's an individual I believe they
just announced an all-female Royal
Rumble or Oh female pay-per-view
evolution I come in 2080 that's right
right what does that mean to you because
that's a huge deal that this is finally
happening
yeah I mean I think there's been
something like over a hundred omen
pay-per-views up to this point so I
think that this is just the first step
in it becoming normal you know like the
first one yes is a huge deal it's the
first one but after a while I think
it'll just become like of course the
women have their own pay-per-view they
do great every single time and I think
it's the first step to normalcy I'm
excited cool thank you so much Congrats
on the movie
you